do you swear to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
well today we're going to find out
because we're making a truth meter
circuit this project is moderately
complicated so we're going to have to
gather a few different things first off
we're going to need a breadboard and
jumper wires some LEDs a variety of
circuit components velcro copper tape a
battery pack and you're going to have to
know how to solder so first let's make
our sensors we're going to make them out
of velcro and they're going to fit over
your fingers so you're going to need two
three to three-and-a-half inch strips of
velcro if you have larger fingers you'll
definitely want to go with three and a
half inches so let's set down our loop
side of the velcro that's the soft side
and now we're going to take the rough
side of the velcro and we're going to
cut a square that'll be roughly 3/4
inches by 3/4 inches so now we're going
to peel the backing off the velcro and
stick them together at one end now we're
going to take our insulated wire and
strip a quarter inch off one end lay the
wire across the back of the soft velcro
so that the exposed portion is hanging
off the end now we're going to take our
copper tape and stick that on the
exposed portion of the soft velcro now
let's strip a little bit off the other
end of the wire now we're going to fold
that exposed wire down over the copper
so now our sensor is essentially done we
just have two more small steps to do
first we're going to trim off the copper
around the edge and secondly we're going
to solder down that exposed wire onto
the copper so it makes a smooth
connection so now that we've got our
sensor all done let's move on to the
circuit so here's our breadboard along
each side we've got power rails red is
positive blue is negative we're going to
connect the positive to the positive and
the negative to the negative
let's connect our finger sensors first
they're going to be in parallel with a 1
mega ohm resistor one of our sensors is
going to be connected to be positive
while one end of the resistor is going
to be connected to be negative this is
our high-pass filter it's going to cut
out extra noise from our circuit it's
got a point 1 micro farad capacitor and
3.3 mega ohm resistor so now we're going
to make a low-pass filter that's going
to connect from the negative input of
our op-amp to its output it uses a 3.3
mega ohm resistor and a 10 nano farad
capacitor in parallel next we're going
to plug a 1k resistor from the output of
our first op-amp
to the negative input of our second
op-amp make sure you double-check your
resistor values just one small
difference can mean the difference
between a 10 kilo ohm resistor and a 1
mega ohm resistor
next we're going to connect a 100k
resistor from the negative input of our
second op-amp to its output now we're
going to make a big giant node that
connects to the positive input of each
op-amp we have our 10k resistor a point
1 micro farad capacitor and 3 diodes in
series you're almost done now just plug
in your 220 ohm resistor your led and
your power supply voila now it's time to
find your victim is it true that your
name is Michael Lennon yes
is it true that you work at wired.com
yes okay so far is it true that you have
a pet lizard named Frankie no so this
circuit is actually measuring galvanic
skin response which is basically your
skin's conductance when you're lying
when you get excited your body releases
tiny little beads of sweat and this
circuit measures that and when it
detects a change that LED lights up